hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
early on in his treatise on truth anselm
is going to bring up
truth in
signification or in statement as we
could call truth in language he also
uses the word orazio meaning speaking
and towards the end he also
clarifies that this would apply to any
other use of
signs fashioned to signify that
something is or is not such as script
and sign language so really anything
that's an externally
oriented way of expressing ourselves
right in relation to others
communication language
what is truth in this and why is he
beginning there because he says
this is the place that we think of most
readily in terms of true and false true
and false statements right statements
about the world that we
live in so we should we should start
there even though this isn't the only
mode of truth and the way that he's
going to
talk about this at first those who have
had like an intro to philosophy
and they encountered the three main
theories of truth the correspondence
theory the coherence theory and the
pragmatic theory they'll immediately say
oh this is a correspondence theory of
truth
yes and no there's a little bit more
involved there so he begins by asking
his student okay when is a statement and
the word for that is
unantacio
true or
false what makes it true or false and
it's very easy to say well you know a
statement is true when it signifies
things the way they actually are so if i
say i'm wearing a black shirt and you
can look at it and say aha that's a
black shirt now you know that the
statement is true it's also true even if
you can't see it because i happen to be
wearing a black shirt now if i was
wearing a white shirt and i said i'm
wearing a black shirt even if you
couldn't see it that statement is false
right so this does sound like a
correspondence theory where there's a
correspondence or an ad equation or
whatever you want to call it between
what's being said
and how things actually
are right so statements can be true
statements can be false they can change
their truth in falsity i can like take
off my shirt and maybe i don't have any
shirt on and i say i have a black shirt
is that a true or false statement well
trivially it's a
false statement right because there's no
shirt at all i mean these are the sort
of things that logicians would get
quite quite
worked up about and so you know when is
something true when what it states
is in fact the case asked
and there's a discussion there about
is the thing that's actually being
stated or signified
the truth itself
and you know the student says no no
because it's not in the statement right
the statement is signifying it but it's
not like there's little bits of the
state of affairs that's being signified
in there no the uh thing that is being
stated is the cause
of the truth of the statement
again to use my shirt the fact that i am
and indeed wearing a black shirt
is what makes the
enunciation the proposition the
statement
i'm wearing a black shirt or dr sadler's
wearing a black shirt a true statement
right
and this gets us pretty far and there's
a lot of examples that they they give
back and forth
and then there's a another thing that
comes up
and so anselm says
let's see whether speech itself
or its signification
or one of the things that is put into
the definition of a statement
might be
what you're looking for and the student
says i don't think so and then the
student says if it were it would always
be true since all the things that are in
the definition of a statement
remain the same whether
what
whether or not what is stated is or not
there is the same statement and the same
meaning and so too with other things so
what is all this talking about
so the definition of a statement
this is a
somewhat unusual way of using the word
definite ceo in latin
meaning the
the structure the the character of a
statement so
i am wearing a
black shirt
there's meaning to that there's
signification that's going on
whether i exist whether shirts exist
whether this shirt happens to be black
or not you're able to understand
what it's saying even with nonsense
words although anselm isn't going into
this there's kind of you know
connotations like think about the
jabberwock an imaginary being you know
it was sly it was brilliant the
slythertoes to jiren jimble and the wave
those are all made up words but there
seems to be something like a meaning
there of connotation even more so for
real
things where we can have a definition
of a an
enunciation or or statement
and this seems to
according to the student always be true
i suppose we could say that there could
be some statements that would always be
false if they contain a contradiction
within them we're not worried about that
here but in general these seem to always
be
true or to have a certain truth to them
that's how they can signify
in the first place and why is this
well there's a lot of possible
explanations and the explanation that
anselm provides here
has to do with linguistic expressions or
significations
doing
what they are supposed to do
doing accomplishing
what they ought to
what they he'll also talk in other
places about things doing what they were
made to you know because god created
them and we could talk about god or we
could talk about human beings and
language
statements
linguistic expressions
do what they're doing at least within a
certain framework
whether what they're referring to exists
or not whether what they're saying
is true or not in terms of
correspondence there is a
meaning a signification there and for
anselm that means that there is a truth
that is always there
and so this is a a real contribution
this is different than merely a
correspondence theory of truth because
what is it corresponding to well you
know a little bit later on
he will talk about uh here we go
cases where an utterance he says when we
say man is an animal or man is not a
stone that affirmation always
signifies that what it is and that
negation that what is is not and we
can't use the former to signify what is
not for man is always an animal
uh nor the latter to signify what is not
because man is always a stone so there's
there's a eternal
truth there in its meaning
this leads anselm to say there's a
twofold
truth and rectitude there's two
different things going on here
there's well let's use the the
you know case
that um he and his student do so the
student says show me how i can answer
someone would say that even when a
statement signifies
that what is not
is it signifies what it should so how do
i deal with statements where it's
clearly false
but it's saying something
he seems to take signifying to apply
equally to what is and what is not
for if it were not taken to signify even
what is not it would not signify
therefore even when it signifies that
what is not is it signifies
what it ought
but if by signifying as it should is
correct and true a statement is true
even when it says
what isn't the case that seems kind of
weird and so this is a way to resolve
that well
it's true in this sense it's false in
this sense
it has a certain as anselm says
immutable truth to it
because it signifies
what it was made to
signify
an interesting translation of this is
it's a well-formed expression but
this means
something a little bit deeper than that
there's this notion here that language
you know has a whole bunch of norms
built into it expressions are made to
signify something whether
what they're signifying really is the
case or not there's signification first
and so significant odd quote significant
focta s
to use the example of the shirt saying
this is a black shirt i'm wearing all of
those expressions
do their work whether i'm wearing a
shirt or not
they do their work of conveying meaning
to you
then there's a changeable or mutable
right
truth as well
or rightness it signifies
what it admits of signifying it it
performs its function as another way of
translating it significant quote
it signifies what it what it you know
should be doing so
in that case my saying this is a black
shirt that's a true statement
the words are doing what they're
supposed to do namely to talk about
something in the world and if i take the
shirt off if i put on a different shirt
now suddenly those words are not doing
what they were you know originally
developed to do
not at least in the sense of referring
to something that is the case right so
both of these truths or rectitudes are
part of the truth of expression and
whether we realize it or not we're
always relying according to anselm on
this immutable
vast network of expressions in language
that signify in order to be able to talk
about whether things are or are not the
case out in the world at all
so this is quite important
in the next chapter we get something
that's very closely related to this
the truth of however we want to which
you know translate it thought
opinion judgment
um he says we also say that thought
is true
when what we think
is the case and false when it is not
that's sort of like how language works
right
language our expressions are true when
they say what is the case when there's a
mapping of one on to the other
well it's the same way with with
thinking if i think that i'm wearing a
gray shirt even though i'm wearing a
black shirt my thoughts are indeed false
right i'm mistaken as we so often say
and he uses a couple terms here opinio
is used in the title right and it'll get
used later on in the work as well
kogatazio that's a thinking and then he
also says razzio reason reasoning
but he also says or other modes aliamoto
right which could include
thinking or
you know assuming or all sorts of other
things
there's a rightness in all of these
that's similar to the rightness that we
find in expression
and it's determined as well in relation
to what one
ought to this quote debit so there's a
similar
structure even though this is a much
shorter
chapter
he says you know the student says truth
of thought could not correctly be called
anything other than its
rectitude or rightness the reason the
ability to think that something is or is
not has been given to us is that we
might
think that what is
is and what is is not so our thought is
correct or incorrect
depending on whether it correlates to
the
realities that we're we're talking about
or perhaps even interior
realities is there also something like
the twofold
truth going on here in thought
we could read that in and assume
that that's there that would be
certainly a good assumption given all
the other things that anselm says but he
doesn't go into that here in this work
so we begin
with
truth in signification truth and thought
something like a correspondence theory
of truth but going beyond it as well
and that is what anselm starts out with
in the de veritate or on truth
you